la selección Colombia femenina realizó
su último entrenamiento antes del
amistoso en el que se enfrentará a la
selección francesa aquí en aquila
selección colombiana que está en plena
gira Europea de Cara a su preparación
antes de este mundial de fútbol que
tendrá lugar en el verano entre
Australia y Nueva Zelanda tuvimos la
oportunidad de hablar con Néstor abadía
el director técnico de Colombia y nos
dijo que era Cuál era la importancia de
este partido para la selección para
nosotros es un reto llamativo es un reto
bueno saber que tenemos este partido con
Francia y más acá en su país ese algo
que es estimulante por lo que es Francia
pero más importante para nosotros es lo
que tenemos y sabemos que debemos hacer
para las francesas también es un partido
importante sobre todo porque será el
primero bajo la batuta de Arjona Después
de varias semanas de crisis y de cambio
por supuesto de entrenador quien dijo en
conferencia de prensa que está seguro de
estar construyendo algo importante pero
que su nivel de exigencia para las
jugadoras va a ser bastante elevado
Además de eso también está la
expectativa de lo público pues ya toda
la boletería para este partido del
viernes se agotó Así que veremos Diez
mil novecientas almas en las graderías
de